[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they arrive at time
then to see what is making the headlines
with the journalist and broadcaster
jenny clement and madeline grant
assistant comment editor at the daily
telegraph with us from now until just
before midnight so welcome to you on
what has been certainly a very busy
evening and before we hear from you
let's look at the front pages starting
with the telegraph which says that boris
johnson's premiership is hanging on by a
thread after the health secretary and
then the chancellor resigned in quick
succession earlier
similarly the guardian says the pm is on
the brink
asd does the financial times
johnson on the brink as ministers quit
their headline
as the metro points out boris johnson is
still clinging onto power despite those
heavy blows with a timeline of what
happened earlier
end games writes the eye
it's last chance saloon
for the sun
while it's curtains for bozo according
to the star
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch our guest this evening so let's go
to jenny and madeline uh with reaction
first of all uh to uh to quite an
evening madeleine you start i mean the
the theme in the papers on the brink you
know last chance saloon how do you see
this shaping out
well i mean it turns out there's there's
many different ways to skin a cat and
there's many different ways to say that
today has been a very uh disastrous day
for the prime minister it's arguably um
the most perilous day of his entire
premiership um and the pm is therefore
in his gravest danger so far i mean it's
it's kind of um this word gets used far
too much in politics these days but it
feels like doubly unprecedented
territory because
under normal circumstances
no conventional prime minister would be
able to survive resignations of this
magnitude losing your your you know
you're the second most powerful person
in your cabinet and
another high-ranking minister
mrs thatcher couldn't survive it theresa
may resigned voluntarily before she was
actually shoved out uh in probably less
serious circumstances but of course in
boris johnson we are not dealing with
the conventional prime minister and we
know that
based on every indicator that we've had
tonight and everything that we know
about him up till now that he will try
to cling on for as long as humanly
possible uh he will have to be prized
out of number 10 um kicking and
screaming and as we've seen uh and as we
will discuss he is already moving very
quickly to try and fill the vacancies in
his cabinet so really the big takeaway
for me is that boris johnson is going
nowhere unless his mps can force him out
yes and i just want to dwell on the on
the telegraph um they point out that mr
javid announced his resignation on
twitter at 6 02 pm
uh while mr sunak tweeted his letter at
6 11 pm and aids to both men jenny
insisted that they did not coordinate
their resignations but then they say
that boris johnson
met a group of about 80 tory mps in a
pre-arranged meeting today moments after
those resignations uh he made clear that
he would carry on and also indicated
that tax cuts would be easier to deliver
after the developments than a swipe at
mr sunac so just your reflections on the
fact that these two specifically have
gone who's replacing them and whether
it's enough to keep boris johnson in
post
what's interesting about the resignation
letters is they're quite different they
uh
they share uh certain factors like they
both seem to be calling on uh boris
johnson to do the right thing and and
calling into question his character his
suitability to lead but rishi sunak was
certainly suggesting in his resignation
letter that boris johnson was suggesting
things and not being straight with the
british public which rishi sunak wanted
to do
so the suggestion being that there was
this undercurrent of tax cuts uh at the
bottom of all of this and uh presumably
nadim zahari the new chancellor will be
more disposed to to be behind them boris
johnson is the optimist he wants to give
uh good news but you know let's put all
of this in context the prime minister
has not just lost the confidence of 75
of his backbenchers he has now
had three cabinet uh resignations uh
with uh with uh uh oliver dowden added
into the mix as well we've also had
seven uh resignations of people in
junior posts uh pps's
trade envoys people are falling uh like
dominoes
uh as madeleine said this has not been
survivable by any other prime minister i
can't think of another time where the
the the chancellor and the health
secretary have resigned on on the same
day the health secretary during a
covered spike the chancellor during a
cost of living crisis and yet the normal
rules do not apply to boris johnson he
is the kind of embodiment of privilege
and and entitlement and he he seems to
think that if he can continue uh this
cycle of scandal lies denial and then
apology that he will somehow get away
with it but i think there is a feeling
now
that this
is the straw that is breaking the
camel's back that this particular who
would have thought uh you know pincher
nobody would have really known his name
a week ago but there is there is just
only so much of this corrosive drip drip
of dishonor that that people can take
and it seems that this is the corrosive
drip that has has kind of burned the
critical hole in in his in his prime
ministership
well the guardian has chosen to quote
from the resignation letter madeleine of
of sanji javed saying we may not have
always been popular but we have been
competent in acting in the national
interest sadly in the current
circumstances the public are concluding
that we are now neither and the
criticism seems to be leveled at boris
johnson that he's running a a populist
government that is neither popular or
competent um you know is that a fair
charge
i think it's a very fair charge i mean
for some time now we've been the the
conservative party has been keeping us
in a kind of bizarre state where uh
normal governance cannot take place
because um
it seems that all of the firepower of
number 10 is devoted towards um dealing
with whatever the latest crisis is and
in fact there have been so many of them
that as jenny says it feels almost
arbitrary that chris pincher should be
the one to tip things over into this
level because there has just been you
know almost a weekly or bi-weekly crisis
um of this magnitude and that makes
means that a number 10 is spending all
its time fighting fires and not getting
on with the business of governing the
country um but b it gradually erodes
that the public's uh trust and any kind
of confidence that they might have had
in that government so you can make your
policy proposals until the cows come
home but i think we've kind of reached a
saturation point now where whatever is
said by number 10 people would say well
this doesn't feel credible these are
just words you know that how do i know
that this might be implemented so we've
almost got into a kind of
post-governance state of of politics um
which is seriously um seriously
untenable and it just so happens that
the chris pincher allegations are the
ones that have cascaded into something
that could no longer be avoided by
those two in the cabinet
well the metro jenny uh with their
headline going going gone uh gone has a
question mark on it because clearly um
they point out that the pm is still
clinging on to power um you know chris
pincher partygate you know those are the
elements of all of this in his control
but should there be some sympathy in
this firefighting government which has
had to deal with a pandemic and now an
energy crisis and a cost of living
crisis and an inflation crisis you know
these are global events uh which have
rocked this government and they're
dealing with as best they can if we're
to use a sympathetic slant on them you
know not all of these crises this series
of crises are in their control
there is a very serious set of problems
facing every country in the world here
we are all recovering from the pandemic
if not already
you know still in it we're in the middle
of a coveted spike as i said at the
moment a cost of living crisis inflation
everywhere which is why it is such a
disgrace that we in this country are
having to deal with the indignities that
boris johnson is is heaping on this
country we are laughing laughing stock
internationally because we are having to
deal on a day-to-day basis with this
ridiculous cycle of different lies
different denials you have cabinet
ministers government ministers uh every
morning going on the rounds talking to
journalists on breakfast tv and on the
radio uh having to defend not policies
but lines that are shown to be lies by
the government any uh fault of of the
government any any crisis that the
government is facing is completely of
boris johnson's own making and yes there
are giant global events but that's what
nobody's complaining about about those
today what we're complaining about is
the complete distraction that boris
johnson uh has become of the work of of
governing this country at a time when we
are crying out for ideas we are crying
out for leadership and what we get is uh
sleaze and lies upon lies and apologies
and an assumption that we the british
public will somehow just forget about
this in a few days time we'll forget
about this that he can sort of gaslight
us and we'll move on but i think you
know we've reached a kind of critical
mass now
where we can't take it anymore and his
cabinets can't take it anymore
well the sun their headline with the
picture of boris johnson um with his
back to us suggesting he's in his last
chance saloon at least they're
suggesting he's got a last chance
because the mood music after those two
resignations madeleine was was that he
was a goner uh already and he's clearly
he's clearly trying to stay in post but
what does he need to do now do you think
to to put some of this behind him
because obviously wednesday he has pmqs
he's got the liaison committee with some
no doubt very challenging questions put
to him in both of those so what needs to
happen for conservative mps and
grassroots to be satisfied
i'm not sure there is anything that
could happen that would satisfy both of
those groups but you know in the long
term i don't really think that boris
johnson's team and boris johnson himself
really think much about the long term i
think they're more interested in
you know the hand-to-mouth survival what
happens next week i think that their aim
right now will be limping on um until we
get to the summer recess in a couple of
weeks and then hoping that over the
summer things calm down a bit maybe
there will be some more they'll make
some more policy announcements in the
hope of just diverting attention away
from the dysfunctionality in number 10 i
don't think that will be successful at
this point i just really cannot fathom
anything that might um secure his
position in the long term but in the
short term i guess we're seeing some of
it already tonight appointing some
people to uh replace those cabinet
resignations appointing nadeem zahari
who's very highly regarded within the
party um and and steve barkley who's
considered to be i think a safe pair of
hands these are kind of quite i suppose
it was the fact that he was able to get
nadeem zahari around to be in his
cabinet that would be seen as quite a
coup for him but i said as i say i think
in the long term um that particular die
is cast i don't really see how um
the prime minister
would be able to turn things around um
at the very least i think that uh it
would he would not be able to turn it
around with the electorate uh
in a future election if there were if
there were to be one
and i suppose if we if we look back at
the the you know at one point they were
talking about boris johnson jenny having
multiple terms in office i suppose the
rot set in uh with the defense of the
former mp owen pattinson which led to
questions about mp's second jobs that
was followed by those partygate
revelations from december onwards but
the the drip drip that uh that tory mps
have had to listen uh to about boris
johnson you know
what we need to know now i suppose is
how many have been tipped over the edge
the former supporters of them certainly
andrew bridgen a vocal critic said today
that he reckoned they could easily have
180 letters to segregate brady the the
chair of the 1922 committee and whether
it it is at that moment the tipping
point of letters that could force him
still out of office
yes i mean you know the backbenchers are
thinking about their constituents
they're thinking about their jobs
they're thinking about whether or not
they could win their seats again at the
next election and when you're talking
about things like the owen patterson
affair which sounds like corruption or
when you're talking about partygate
which sounds like one rule for them and
another rule for us which i think still
really stings a lot of people we all
know what we were doing during those
lockdowns and and the vast majority of
us were not having parties um these are
things that voters don't forget and i
think boris johnson thought he had got
away with it because of the way that the
1922 committee works but there were
going to be elections in the 1922
commission committee the rebels are
trying to get representation on the
executive so that the rules can be
changed and so there can be another vote
of no confidence imagine if that vote
was taking place now and imagine those
people who voted that they did have
confidence only a few weeks ago how many
of them would be voting in the same way
today
well i wondered when i arrived here
today whether we'd see the bags being
packed in uh number 11 downing street as
rishi sunak leaves but then people
reminded me that he actually gone in
about april after all those revelations
about the financial dealings of his wife
and his green card and so on uh there is
number 11. it's lit up as you can see no
doubt the work is still going on they're
still offices as we've heard many a time
in in downing street um and nadine zaha
we will move in eventually uh one
presumes we've got the times in as well
actually madeleine johnson on the brink
we'll certainly discuss that and the
incomers in those two crucial posts and
cabinet after this break
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now once again
the journalist and broadcaster jenny
clement and madeline grant assistant
comment editor at the delhi telegraph
welcome back to both of you um let's go
to the times then um you know once again
the word brink being used for this paper
picture of boris johnson on the front
cover as well and i have to say um they
have written their view as a leader
column as well jenny the times beyond
boris johnson's position game over they
say the prime minister has lost the
confidence of his party and the country
he should now quit now rather if the
conservatives are to have any chance of
winning the next general election and
we remember that the conservative party
you know it's tough on its leaders it
knows when it wants them to go
and uh it's all about winning seats for
parliamentarians and winning power for
the conservatives
the wording of this leader is incredibly
strong this times leader it says serial
dishonesty has corrosive effect on
effective government
and also on our country and and this is
it it's about our reputation as well and
and here you have somebody who is
abjectly clinging on to power even
though it is not in the interest of his
party of government or of this country
and uh you know
the front page story of the times has an
extraordinary quote from boris johnson
when it was suggested to him this
evening that he might go he apparently
said
f that
what kind of person looks at this mutiny
of those closest to him these are people
with experience and knowledge and and
bearing in mind the boris johnson
doesn't necessarily value experience and
knowledge he values loyalty and his
cabinet is largely comprised of biddable
people that he he has amassed around him
because he knows they'll support him uh
but what kind of person looks at this
scenario and thinks you know what would
be best for the country if i don't
change anything that i'm doing it's
absolutely extraordinary and for the
times to be saying this is really quite
significant because you know this is a
newspaper that has uh supported boris
johnson in in the past and even even
quite recently so this is a very
significant turning point i'd say
well you think the uh the times uh
leader article is bad uh jenny we just
had the daily mail and we'll show you in
a minute i'm not sure we've quite got
the image of it uh but i'll read you the
headline can even boris the greased
piglet wriggle out of this suggesting it
was the most tumultuous night the most
dramatic night in westminster since the
toppling of margaret thatcher
you know we remember this for general
elections don't we just before the vote
the newspapers come down on what they
think should happen who people should
vote for here we're starting to see the
newspapers with their view on what this
prime minister should do and the
question i suppose is how influential
still are the newspapers when they make
their mark and their comment like this
madeleine
i don't think they're particularly
influential i think newspapers tend to
um i don't think they shape opinions so
much as they reflect the opinion of
their readers and they play to their
audience um which is perhaps a slightly
controversial view of newspapers given
like a work for one but i i think that
on the whole the
the influence of the newspapers is not
nothing close to where it used to be in
previous decades when far more people
read a paper every day um but no i think
that what we're seeing here is
newspapers
like to back a winner on the whole
and
it's clear that many new
newspapers as well as what the views of
the
editorial
section
feel about the prime minister and his
faults i also think that um newspapers
like to be
anticipating the mood of of their
readers and of the country and i suppose
being ahead of the game and and to back
a winner that's that tends to be quite
important for newspapers so i think in
that sense it shows that the tide is
turning from people who watch
westminster very carefully and are now
seeing that um just hearing this is
another situation
madeleine apologies i'm just going to
butt in alex chalk solicitor general has
resigned to add to that list so one more
we thought perhaps it was over for
tonight but it seems not